This video is sponsored by Bokksu.
No other character represents the moral landscape
of the one piece world as well as Monkey D.
Garp, the hero of the marines.
As the father of the most wanted person in
the world as well as the grandfather of the
future pirate king and the son of the old
one, garp without any doubt plays a quite
unique role in the story, especially given
the fact that he is one of the most respected
members within the marines, the sworn enemy
of pirates and revolutionaries alike.
And yet, the two defining traits of his character,
next to his kindhearted and goofy nature are
his strong sense of duty as well as his love
for his criminal family.
And as we will see, it is exactly this stark
polarization of beliefs that make him such
a tragic and lovable person.
This is the story of Monkey D. Garp.
Garp is mostly known for two feats, the defeat
of the rocks pirates on god valley, as well
as the capture of gol d.
Roger.
Even tough garp has enjoyed immense respect
and special treatment within the marines for
them, both of these events have been doctored.
As we now know, Roger actually handed himself
in willingly to trigger the next pirate era.
Meanwhile, he actually fought side by side
with garp to defeat rocks, which makes it
very hard to assess how strong he truly is.
since he was able to fight with some of the
most powerful beings in the one piece world
however and was offered the position of admiral
multiple times, it is pretty safe to assume
that garp is very much the real deal.
From a storytelling perspective, garp actually
has a quite unique character design.
Or, to put it in better terms, he doesn't
seem to fit in any traditional trope or category.
Even though he is the grandfather to both
luffy and ace, and was the one who trained
them both, he doesn't really fit the trope
of the classical old man mentor.
That role falls to Rayleigh for luffy and
to whitebeard for ace. a better fit might
be that of a parental figure, that he Cleary
is to both of the boys.
However while he showered both of them with
love, he also didn't exactly stick around
all too much.
in the end, I believe that garp is several
important supporting characters mashed into
one.
he represents the old era from the marines
perspective, that includes other legends,
like Roger or whitebeard.
He is a father figure to the main character,
balanced in such a way that luffy has experienced
both love and care in his childhood, while
still benefitting from the classical shone-hero-without-parents
trope, that gives him independence and drive.
Kind of ironic actually that luffy mostly
grew up an orphan, even though he has an actual
father and grandfather who are both still
alive and well.
The biggest role garp plays in the story however,
is that he represents the blurred moral lines
between the different groups operating in
the one piece world like no other.
as we all know, the notion that all marines
are good and all pirates are evil is pretty
much thrown out the window within the first
few chapters.
instead, we learn that there are good marines
and bad marines, just as there are good pirates
and bad pirates.
And of course a ton of people who fall somewhere
in between.
We know that the marines, while claiming to
fight for peace and justice, also serve at
the will of the celestial dragons, a tyrannical
regime of hedonic slave owners.
At the same time, while a lot of pirates simply
seek freedom from this regime of oppression,
many are just as terrible on the other end
of the table, killing and terrorizing the
innocent civilians who are helplessly caught
between both fronts.
And Monkey D. Garp is the personification
of the question: What does it mean to be good.
This is actually a really interesting theme
in the monkey family.
While luffy values family above all else,
as we see with his crew and ace, and rejects
any sense of duty to any system, his father
Dragon ended up putting duty above all else,
even if it meant abandoning his own child.
Garp meanwhile is literally torn between both
duty and family, looking for a way to balance
them, not always successfully.
In the end, what all three of them desire
in the end is freedom and a just world, free
of the terror of the celestial dragons, but
also from pirates like Blackbeard or doflamingo.
However, based on each of their ideals, Luffy
chose the path of piracy, dragon that of the
revolutionary and garp that of the marine.
And while luffy represents the best within
the world of pirates, garp very clearly embodies
the best within the marines.
His approach to justice - I have actually
talked about that off the 4 admirals as well
- are by far the most human and relatable,
making him the flagship of the type of marines,
that we as an audience want to see, and that
inn the future will likely end up becoming
the new normal.
This includes people like smoker or Aokiji,
who see him as a role model, but also a line
of young marines like Coby, who garp chose
and trained himself.
I would argue then that garp, as a member
of the d.
Clan and the notorious monkey family is the
one who is quietly nursing a more just and
independent generation of marines, with the
freedom and desire to actually work for and
protect the people and not the celestial dragons.
Before we move on to the tragic part of Garps
character however, let's first lighten the
mood a bit.
As you may or may not know, it's finally the
long awaited sakura season here in Japan.
And to celebrate the occasion the kind folks
over at Bokksu sent me this wonderful snack
box.
Bokksu is a monthly snack box subscription
service that delivers original assortments
of premium Japanese snacks and tea pairings,
directly from Japan to wherever you live.
And as I get it, there is a different theme
for every season, and since I love hanami,
I got lucky and got the sakura one.
Let's open this bad boy up and see what's
inside.
Cause I absolutely love the snacks here in
Japan.
---
What I really like about this, is that they
collaborate with traditional Japanese family
manufacturers that make these snacks and candies.
So you don't just get some random stuff you
can in any Japanese supermarket, but actual
local stuff.
Especially when you're outside of Japan, this
is a really great opportunity to try some
authentic Japanese food.
If you would like to try it out for yourself,
you can get 10% off your own Bokksu snack
box and save up to $47 using my code & link
in the description below!
And this brings us back to the tragedy of
Garps character.
His inner divide between love towards his
family and duty towards the organization he
believes to bring justice to the world.
[Jon Snow]
We can see this divide very Cleary in the
the fact that garp has a very interesting
approach to dealing with pirates, which is
judging them based on their actions and their
personality, as he is well aware of the dark
system overshadowing the marines.
We know this, because garp doesn't make a
secret out of his disdain for the world nobles.
in fact, the only reason he never accepted
any promotion above vice admiral was, because
the positions of admiral and fleet admiral
are under the direct command of the world
government.
As a result, similar to smoker and luffy started
to build an actual relationship with Roger
after chasing after him for many years.
In the end, their relationship was of such
mutual respect and understanding, that they
not only fought together, Roger actually entrusted
garp with his precious child, telling him
that he trusted him as much as his crew, which,
lets be honest is a real goosebump moment.
Whether he also told garp about his plans
and the knowledge he found on laugh tale remains
to be seen, but garp was willing to accept
his old rivals request and took Ace in.
Garp entrusts Ace to Dadan And some time later,
Luffy too, occasionally paying them visits
and hoping to shape them into future Marines.
each have their own reason to become a pirate
and disobey him.
But this doesn’t change the fact that they
are family.
He continues to pour his love on them, albeit
through fists of love.
And Garp wanting Ace And Luffy to become Marines
shoes us how much he actually respects his
job, no doubt hoping to make his boys part
of his new generation.
And yet he keeps laughing whenever he hears
about luffs exploits in the world, even when
the marines are involved.
And so its no real surprise that marineford
was not only the climax of luffys character
arc, but of grapes as well.
When he sits next to his grandson, who is
about to be executed, There was not a hint
of a smile.
Garp instead cries.
Cries not only in sorrow of seeing his grandson
in such a situation, but cries because of
his inability to do anything about it.
His life as a Marine tied his hands up.
In the end, garp decides to choose duty.
As he takes down Marco, who had no issues
dealing with the other admirals so far, he
boosts the morale of the marines.
And just moments later, he has to witness
Luffy, his second grandson, running towards
him.
The ultimate dilemma.
Now he was standing in the way of one grandson
rescuing his other grandson.
In this moment of turmoil, as he sees his
happy days with the boys pass before his eyes,
he gives himself up and allows Luffy to punch
him and pass.
And so I believe that the true reason Garp
is so incredibly enraged at akainu killing
ace, is that right from the start, he never
actually thought Ace was going to be executed.
Instead, he fully expected Whitebeard and
his crew and later luffy would save Ace.
As a result, we got one of the most emotional
and heartbreaking scenes in the story as Sengoku
has to restrain him from murdering akainu.
And the same goes for his reaction to shanks
arriving, who was responsible for setting
luffy on the same path as ace.
And so on this day, Garp, the Marine won.
But Garp, the man, lost.
Now I personally would like to think, that
garp will have the chance to choose again
at some point in the future, so save his other
grandson or stay loyal to the marines.
And this time he will choose family over duty.
If you want to watch more of my character
anlysis, you can simply click up here.
Or, my latest video, right down there.
Thanks for watching, peace.